hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swoosh whataled podcast for those
who are new to the podcast swish is an
awesome platform which gives you the
opportunity to get a video message from
some of your favorite sports stars it is
the perfect gift idea and is very very
affordable and for the listeners in the
uk in particular london irish fans who
have come on to listen to today's guests
there is a great london irish lad on
swish and ben loder one of the great
lads and a whole heap of other stars
from all around the world it's been
awesome hearing from people who've given
it a go loved what they received back
from their sports star and the best
thing about it all is that a large
portion of the proceeds do go to kiwi
kids charities and don't forget there is
a 10 discount for all the led listeners
who use the code what a lad i'll leave a
link in the description below so you
just need to click on that also
puresport who are the most tested and
trusted cbd oil on the planet are kindly
offering 20 of all their products with
the discount code what a lad 20 so that
all of the listeners can be safe from
any muscle or joint pain they may have
without chewing back some harsh
anti-inflammatories
they also have oil specific for your
sleep energy and immunity distress and
calm or even maybe just your focus
if you're after help in any of those
areas then this is a great place to
start trust me
righto let's get to it roll the intro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well today i'm honored to
be in the presence of a reality tv star
who has recently been on the hit show
the apprentice but before he was a tv
star he was an irish rugby god playing
age grade rugby for ireland before being
picked up by leinster and he then moved
to london irish where he became a club
legend there and as well as all that he
is one of the most energetic and best
lads to be around you will ever meet it
is the great connor gilson and welcome
mate jimmy what an intro thank you so
much um i need to bring you around to
all my networking events and pick me up
like that
it's so good to be here i i genuinely
feel like i've got imposter syndrome
because you've just had
a long list of
of all blacks on the show and they said
you've just pulled me into nowhere just
like this
this absolute um this wrong trump card
but look i'm looking forward to sharing
a few stories with you mate you're one
of the biggest lads i've played with so
i can't wait to get into this one great
good stuff but mate life post starring
at the apprentice what's that been like
for you it's actually been really good i
it's been a whirlwind of emotions i i
went in there expecting a lot from it um
and incorrectly so i expected too much
ended up getting dumped out after two
weeks
so i was pretty aggrieved after that
i took i took 12 weeks holidays
unpaid holidays to go do this things i
thought it was going to be in for the
long haul i bought five new suits i only
got to wear three of them
i was i was seated when i came out for
like six weeks i just wanted to talk to
long sugar be like you made a wrong call
and then
i got over that and then christmas kind
of came round and you know the people
who knew about it
were like how you feeling about i
started getting quite anxious i was like
i don't know how i'm going to be
perceived here i've just started a new
job that could make me out to be
something i'm not yeah so that was quite
nervy times and then when it came out
and the week build up so it was actually
a lot of fun yeah i i enjoyed it i was
get i
[Laughter]
we didn't get it here over in new
zealand which was a bit of a shame but
i was just shocked does anyone to see
that you were out second round what what
actually happened okay
what happened um
so the first task kind of like played it
safe and it was it was chaos it was
total chaos eight guys from
all different backgrounds very strong
personalities and
you're trolling together to do this you
know bordering on impossible tasks
create marketing campaign for a cruise
liner in
24 hours and then present it to all
these experts so you're just like it was
just a minefield of
of things that could go wrong and we we
tripped on every everything we could
have gone wrong
but i managed to like stare at the fire
line and then i was like you know what
i'm feeling confident after that first
round
um i'm gonna take ownership of this and
put myself forward as one of the leaders
of the team and we created this kids 2
brush and basically what happens is
today seven guys came together
we the leader pitched this vision and i
looked after one team and he looked
after the other team you go away for the
day
and then the next day you present
what you built so i built um an app for
a kid's toothbrush and he went and built
the toothbrush yeah and the theme that
we went for was like a magical brushing
wand
and i was like i quite liked the concept
i thought the kids bought into it
it was easy to follow
he went off and created a product and
the plot the colors they went for were
brown and this is something that like
sits in the louvre
the wizard i call whiffy the wizard
and
we we pitched we pitched at the super
drunk the next day and the guy was like
they'll never crossed your mind you
created a product that looks like
eternity you called it whiffy and i'm
going i can't believe this has happened
oh and this is like like five million
people watch this show on a daily basis
and then it goes right up to like nine
um when they do the on-demand stuff yeah
so a lot of people watch show and you're
going i can't believe it i look so silly
but
i probably to be totally honest i
probably shouldn't have been fired but
yeah these things happen and so it was a
really good fun great experience and i'm
glad i did it and it's actually been
really good for the for the business
that i've set up with topsy yeah which
i'm sure we'll talk about at some point
yeah and how set up is it on the on the
set is it all pretty staged or is it
like it looks um it's definitely on
stage like everything you're seeing is
real it's just
you're just getting pulled in a lot of
different directions and you are quite
restricted in what you can do i can't
say it too much um
but it's it's it put it this way it's
not as easy as it looks yeah on tv
you're going like because you're making
these decisions as the day progresses
and you're submitting your answers and
then if something doesn't really make
sense as the day goes on it's very
difficult to go back and change it
and then you've got to get so much done
throughout the day that like it's very
you pretty much can't sense check
anything so like of course
you go whiffy the wizard and then the
next morning wake up and go whiffy's
probably not a great name
but like you can't you can't change it
you know what i mean so
and it makes for great tv like it's car
crash stuff and i actually people are
like it couldn't have been that chaotic
i'm like the editors have actually been
kind in it like it's actually way more
chaotic than they look good and they
make it out to me
and were you happy with the way you were
portrayed as a individual i thought it
was fair yeah yeah i was i was really
nervous because you know they can do
whatever they want they edit and they
were fair like i said some stupid stuff
and i got lured into what they're trying
to get you to do to play up to the tv
but that's all part of it
you know there was a no there was an
opening scene like when i was the first
episode
actually it's a bit long with the story
but i'll probably probably worth telling
so basically
you kind of have to like submit what
you're going to wear for uh
the boardroom yeah and you have to stick
to that outfit and i showed all we went
to do these entrance shots the week or
two week four went in and i showed up
and
um i like changed my shirt and tie like
last minute i didn't really think it was
a big deal
we got there and they were like oh we
have to like stick to what you sent
across originally and i was like okay
fine so we'd go through to
my entrance shop was like catwork
airport
and we went in
and
we i went and bought like the shirt and
toy that i needed basically
and my glasses were like reflected badly
with the with the cameras so we needed
to like get ones that were like
anti-glare and i hadn't gone and done
that so
i went into sunglasses hot and high
because like i needed a clear pair of
clear lens aviators to just get me
through today
and they just
sold me a pair and i was like sweet
they'll do the job
so then go do my shots then i went to do
this like on-screen interview which was
really really hard it was like an hour
of
them asking all these questions and
they're just looking for sound bites
something that makes you
uh look a bit ridiculous and it's
memorable that makes for good tv you're
trying so hard to find a balance between
i want to give them what they want here
because you want to come across as
boring but equally i don't want this to
haunt me for the rest of my life
and
i was just like i'm never calling i
remember like being like this is so hard
like what am i signed up for here and
i came off
i came off the set i took my glasses off
and the glasses had like they've gone
tinted and i'm inside i'm like
what has happened here obviously got one
of these glasses that like react to the
uv light and then go
turn into sunglasses i like turning
right into the camera i'm like
did you know my
glasses were
very like tinted there he's
he's uh he just smiled at me and nodded
and i was like oh god i hope it doesn't
matter and then the first scene
um was me saying something like super
cheesy and i'm wearing sunglasses inside
you know what it can't get any worse
than this
so it made it made watching the next two
episodes like an absolute breeze i'm
totally honest
oh that's good stuff you spoke about um
sort of regretting going oh what made
you want to go on at the in the first
place how did that whole process happen
so i've always liked been a massive fan
of the show yeah i was looking
i could do a good job of this um
back myself to be like quite creative
and um
and quite like good in team environments
so i was like i have i've done like
quite a few startups
and then the experience from rugby all
those things i was like i can i can do a
good job of this and
um when rugby finished i was like
given my background and then sport they
tend to like have an ex sports athlete
on there they always have an irish
person on there so when i was going
through the application process they
were like why should we pick you and i
said
listen you always have a washed up
sports athlete and a token irish person
on the show you can kill two birds at
once
and
i think i think they enjoyed that but
yeah i just said look this is it's a
it's a unique fun experience i'm at like
a bit of a crossroads of my life in
terms of transitioning away from the
game i'm not like into the tick of a new
career yet
and i was always going to go set up this
business with topsy so i was like at the
very minimum it would be a brilliant
life experience i get some exposure from
uh for the for the 301 and then you know
if you go and you win these things you
go really far like
you're a really good platform to
to springboard yourself on to whatever
you choose to do after that so that was
my thinking behind it i knew the risks
associated with it that like
you can come across really badly on tv
say the wrong thing that will haunt you
for the rest of your life
but overall it was really short it was
too short-lived for me to do any of that
stuff i didn't even catch everyone's
name
and none of that's what's happened and i
i really i really enjoyed how i would
come out and i've no regrets i've no
regrets about doing it has anything
changed for you post the show
it's been good for you know we've had a
lot of inquiries for the bar which is
which has been great um
it didn't i didn't lose my job over the
night
and um yeah i don't know it's kind of in
a weird way it's
even though it went didn't go well for
me i still like has given me an i've
always had a pip in my step but like an
extra pip of my step you know one maybe
to kind of prove a point that like i'm
very capable and then yeah you just kind
of feel like you gotta go make this
happen there right you gotta like you've
gone set up this business
there's probably a little bit more
exposure on it than they normally would
be so um
it's on my lap to make a success of it
and to make a success myself so has
given me applied a bit of healthy
pressure yeah and it's been a brilliant
experience i enjoy
i enjoy telling the stories from it you
know me i i love a good war story which
has probably been a big part of it
do people recognize young straight
i got it i was i was on a golf weekend
with some friends on saturday and heard
richard and i had a few people quote one
guy because that's he goes you're an
irish guy shane from the apprentice
all right you got my name wrong yeah on
that guy
i was like
i'll let you off on that one um give it
i'm sure i was in there first you get a
little bit and then obviously the first
game after i got fired
on the large plate edinburgh and
it was no it's normally always tough so
you get the attention at the bar but
like this weekend
topsy would have been filthy
yeah i know
he loves the live lifestyle he's getting
lots of it man he is he's crushing it
and tv stuff over here at the minute and
every time i look at my screen if it's
on bbc itv
bt he's always there i'm like i can't
get a hold of you to have a chat about
the bar
you're too busy on tv all the time
yeah that's awesome he's doing well i
can't believe you're a reality tv star
how good is that i'm not i'm not i'm not
but before we get too far into it i do
hear plenty of stories about how guys
grew up in new zealand i sort of know
that lifestyle but first irish local i'm
really looking forward to hearing what
it's like for you growing up in ireland
that's awesome um an honor to be the
first irish person you've had on the pod
local i mean we've had jamison gibson
park who's now fully irish but um a few
others
but you're the first born and bred oh
awesome that's that's really cool
yeah so i i grew up in a in a rural town
called mullingar which is like an hour
west of dublin when i'm describing it to
the people from from new zealand who
maybe
aren't familiar with geography i'm
almost like if you're true if you're
true with dart dot if ireland was a dark
board in true dark that it were bulling
guards at bullseye so
it's it's one of the rainiest towns in
ireland
um it's got about twenty thousand or
twenty five thousand people living there
um yeah i had a really really fond
memories growing up there i grew up in a
an entrepreneurial household my mom and
my parents were undertakers and
and publicans so
they were they were busy juggling two
businesses and growing up
and i was going to the crux of it i
played a lot of sport growing up um like
gaelic football hurling
soccer rugby
swimming tennis um like a lot of parents
are kind of busy doing taxi to all these
things and then when i was when i was 12
years old i shot off the board in school
but always kept in close contact with
mullingar and i still my parents still
love the pub still love the undertaker
business
and i'm still very close with a lot of
my friends from there and actually
there's a lot of them who who live over
here
in in london with me now um so yeah
that's that's kind of where i'm from may
i know you mentioned your friend and i'm
surprised we've got this far without you
talking about him about your good mate
niall
who will be
who will be familiar to a lot of our
listeners uh
when were you guys friends from what age
yeah since we're about nine or ten i
would say uh maybe even a little bit
younger than that but we both grew up in
mullingard um kind of in the same
friendship groups
played a bit of sport together and then
yeah he went on to do some literally
like took over the world
which was which is
awesome to see such a cool thing for
someone from one guard to
achieve such scary height of success um
pretty inspiring for a lot of people i
think you know there are some there are
a lot of good musicians from mullingar
um
none i've managed to get to the heights
he have and i'm not sure anyone if
anyone will ever replicate it because
they're they're pretty unprecedented but
yeah he left to do the x factor when
he's about 15 or 16 and i'll actually
remember it was he only fifth day
15 or 16 16. yeah he left school when he
was 16. but me one of my best friends uh
stephen devoine and now we went to watch
westmead playing crow park so westmead
is the county them from and we play
gaelic football and
they were playing loud or something it
was like a nothing game we had to watch
that and then he he was going off he was
going back there the next day through
the
x factor auditions and i remember being
like uh best of luck with that tomorrow
kind of thing
not really not really like taking much
would come of it like he was always so
passionate about
about music and was always doing like
the gigs and stuff in town and was
really popular like locally but
next thing i heard he was like at the
judge's houses and
then they went on this
this crazy run and became the biggest
boy band
maybe the world has ever seen like i
remember watching the beatles
movie with him
the beatles or oasis or one of those
like you're watching it all happen and
he's kind of sitting there silently
watching it going how cool is that and
i'm like
you've done that
you lived that life for a few years
um
but yeah he was great when i moved over
to london originally
i didn't really know many irish people
over here you know there's an army of us
here now
but he took me under his wing brought me
to some really really cool events and uh
introduced me to a lot of people and
really helped me find my face
did his success in a reality tv show
sort of make you want to do this
apprentice show even more was that any
part of it no no no not nothing to do
with that at all but
the thing is the apprentices right like
like nobody really gets
famous from us yes
it's it's a some people do really well
and business off the back of it but
it was described really well to me in
the lead up to it they were like if this
is what you're going on here to do
you've got the wrong show um
the attraction is is the show and people
love the show they don't necessarily
attach to the people that come off it
and that go on to it and come off the
other end of it and that is true because
like those viewership numbers like five
million people watched it um before and
like week one and two and i think went
up to five and week three and
like you look at the people who are are
on have been on the show like their
instagram followers are
i don't think anyone's over like
10 000 or not so
it's not translating into each
individual's personal brand per se the
people certain people who will go far
will do well office um and then it's up
to everyone else the people who crashed
out early to to make a good fist with
themselves
and by all accounts you were a really
good choir singer as well did you ever
think about going to the expected with
him no
i i haven't gotten old in my head but
you were a choir singer though right
yeah how do you know
that question came in a lot apparently
you were a wizard
i i used when i was in primary school i
was in the choir where i wasn't very
good um
yeah i wasn't very good i enjoy i enjoy
a good sing song with a few drinks on me
but that's about the height of it yeah
okay but anyway we'll go back to you
you mentioned you were really good at a
lot of sports why rugby and why not the
gaelic football path um when i was
growing up i think i kind of preferred
gaelic football and i was probably
better at it as well and played for my
local team called one and guy shamrocks
and
had some unbelievable memories with a
bunch of guys that i went through the
age group there we won everything we
went
we won the county championships and
there's this tournament called uh
the fella and
um
one representative from each county goes
to play in this like blitz over three or
four days um and it's in like a small
town in ireland
and they turn it into like a massive
festival and you get like you're 14
years old you get these massive crowds
of these games and you're representing
your county and it's it's very very
prestigious so we we got to the
fella but we didn't manage to win it
and then we won like all the the county
level stuff growing up 14 16 minor level
and
yeah i was loving my football but i went
to longo's went to boarding school when
i was 13 and it's just like a rugby
crazy school and you just get drawn in
from it like again
i don't know if the guys have any irish
guys have been have spoken about it on
your pod but
it's crazy the level of professionalism
and the attention that the tournaments
get and it's difficult not to get drawn
in but
and
yeah you just get you get drawn into
rugby when
when you're in a school like longo's and
we had a really really good batch of of
guys in our age group and we were really
successful so then
we won everything we won junior cup
trophy which is the first time our
school had won it like 56 years
and then when i got to the senior cup
level we won it two years consecutively
and anyone who's from um from ireland
and like played in that tournament
that's really hard to do
so off the back of that a lot of us got
opportunities to go into academies and
represent ireland at age grade level
and when that's knocking on your door
um you just
you're obviously going to say yes and
you're going to get drawn towards taxes
offering your career path um so that's
that was that was where the decision
came from i've always kind of like been
tempted to go back playing gaelic but
i'm not sure i had to stop because of my
head so i'm not sure if it allowed me to
do that yeah so that that's how it kind
of all came about um
choosing choosing rugby over
over gaelic and then you made the irish
junior national sides all the way
through didn't you so you were a quality
player from a young age um yeah well
thanks for the kind words
to take those things
well that's that's a nice way to put it
when when i'm knocking around with my
school friends they were like you
you you peaked when you were 18. it all
went downhill from there
which
pretty pretty
true honest it all happened for me quite
quickly
i was like winning everything in school
like playing for ireland or 18 and then
we got to captain ireland at 90 and then
went to the 20s world cup was that was
all happening and yeah
and i didn't really manage to kick on
from there to be totally honest
so from that you went into the leinster
environment didn't you yeah and what was
that like um that was unbelievable it's
such a it's such a good place to learn
um it's such a good club and they've got
such a conveyor about the talent coming
through and it's such a the academy
everything about it is just top top
level and i'd come out of school i'd
spent my whole all my school years like
supporting land store i was a die-hard
fan i was over at
murrayfield when they won the first
heineken cult that's true against
leicester and i actually i actually ran
onto the page after the game i was like
the first person on the page i remember
i was like i was weaving in and out of
these uh
these security guards and they could not
catch me i was like people like jump i
was like getting a real riser in the
crowd
and then this one guy got my shoe in the
dead ball line i was kind of going for
um i was going to get out and try to get
back in the crowd and
caught me and then some guy came from
behind me and stuffed me in the back and
that got like a rapturous uh
rapturous response to the crowd and then
they pretty much like arrested me and
like took me in today's security room
and they were like you're in a lot of
trouble son um i was only 16
i was like oh here we go this is a
disaster my dad's to be so stressed i
went with my dad
and
i was like they were like yeah they're
taking this really seriously this year
you're in a lot of trouble you're going
to be spending a night in the clink and
i was going oh my god i've never been in
trouble with the police before this yeah
and then as
as time went on just more and more
people like leinster fans started piling
into this security room and they were
all pissed off and singing molly malone
and it just got too much for them they
were like just get out get out like yeah
you're getting away with this one
it was funny i got out and i ragged my
dad he was like got her got her i have a
solicitor here we're looking after you
and i was like don't worry dad
i'm off the hook
so
yeah again i i'm getting sidetracked
there but
i basically said i was like a massive
final answer growing up so that you go
into this environment and
on the first day you're like shaking
hands with with brian o'driscoll and leo
cullen and uh
and shane horgan and these guys and
they're introducing themselves by their
first name and you're like
you really don't need to do that i know
exactly who you are you were a massive
fan of idris kuwait
o'connell o'brien gordon darcy rob
carney all that generation like they
were proper role models for me
um
so to be like rubbing shoulders with
these guys even though like it was i was
in the academy but you were you're
working in the same place with them
every day and getting to see how they do
things and
all very approachable people as well
like very happy to help you learn so
that was
so cool and super inspiring and you're
just like you just want to get there
like it's just every day you're just
trying to get better and trying to prove
that like you're you're capable of
making the step up to the first team
and you've got all the tools at your
disposal there to do it unfortunately
that didn't didn't materialize for me
for multiple different reasons but i had
a really good time there and i learned a
lot there and it definitely stood me in
good stead for the rest of my career
what were those reasons you didn't
manage to get a crack with them um
i went from school like straight into
the academy
with some really really good like class
players i went in that year with with ty
burn
luke mcgrath
and type furlong and james tracy
like all these guys have gone on to play
for lions internationally and
i've had amazing careers and we're with
a really good bunch of guys and they're
all collect my irish 20s age group as
well
i'm forgetting loads of guys there as
well so apologies
in case they're listening
but we
yeah we went in there our first year was
was pretty positive for me i played most
of my rugby with the irish 20s and we
did a good run in the six nations we won
our first four games and we were on for
a grand slam against england and kind of
didn't go well first in that last game
we we got hockey in england which was
pretty disappointing but we're really
good throughout the tournament and then
we got to the the 20s world cup that
year and was down in south africa we
played the host and we beat them and
they were like really heavily fancied
and we're like right this is on so we
played england the next game
and we're like 14 now
you ended up losing that game and i i
went off and judged from the sydney
osmosis and
i fractured my ankle as well
so that tournament was over and i missed
pre-season and one of my biggest
struggles throughout my whole career was
like putting on size and i played in the
background i'm not naturally like a
well-built unit like for sure like i'm
down to like 88 90 kilos
welcome to the club
and then my second year in the academy i
played pretty much for my played for my
wcd and played with the a team
we won our tournament that year it's
called the british irish cup which was
uh the first time we'd done it that was
a great achievement
um i don't know why we ucd but i haven't
managed to get any any game timer wasn't
really even close to it in retrospect
getting game time in my second year
so then you like really need to start
making inroads in your virginia you need
to start showing that you're off the
plane man's being you're capable of
putting pressure on the guys who are
ahead of me
there's a really good bunch of
like all of them are international back
rower um
but i still like was like if i just get
like my foot in the door i can go in
there i can compete
and
start to start my third year in the
academy and it went pretty well like i
had a good preseason i was training with
the first team
um and then i got injured again yeah
again because it's kind of like this
this narrative repeat itself quite a lot
as this goes on
but i got injured again
and
a good opportunity once i got fit a
really good opportunity came about where
i had the opportunity to go down to
connect and play for a same rugby play
like counting corporate champions cup
rugby because they had an injury crisis
at open side and the arrangement was i
go down there and do that but on the
pretense that i signed for land stay the
following season on a development
contract and i was like
jackpot i'm gonna go down here i'm gonna
get like first team rugby um top tier of
european rugby
coming back to the club i love um and
i'll come back a better player and like
more capable of challenging for
what's in the guys ahead of me
and and that weekend jordy murphy and
shane jennings
both picked up like medium term injuries
like one and broke their hand and the
other one hurt their ankles and
matt o'connor who was the first team
coach at the time he was like
no mate you can't go down we're going to
be short staffed at open side and i did
push i was like this is like for my
development this is really good but he
wasn't too fussed he was just like nah
you're hanging around
but they were like look there's there's
still going to be a development contract
there for you for next season so just
like keep progressing where you're doing
um we'll get that sorted and then i just
like naively just didn't go about
getting that signed i just kind of
assumed it would be there and
like all things happened rugby like
things change and i i picked up a
more significant injury i had to get
knee operation a few weeks later and
then that contract wasn't there for me
once i got back fit wow yeah it's kind
of felt like you're on the cusp of
really like breaking in and um
on the irish scene and then once you get
your once you get going in there like
they're very much like new zealand
they're about promoting and holding on
to homegrown talent so yeah like in
retrospect had that
you know if that had happened maybe gone
and got first team explosion and came
back to leinster things might have been
a little bit different but
that didn't play out that way
and then that's when i you know the
opportunity came to go to london irish
and i just jumped that i was like this
is awesome playing premiership rugby
go with you with the connection to the
irish roots and i'm moving to london as
a 21 year old you know it's the terms of
a new challenge and an exciting
challenge you don't go much better than
that and how did you find that london
lifestyle i loved it well and i still do
love it i'm a big believer when you get
you get bored alone and you get bored of
life it's it's got so much going on i've
i've really trolled myself into the deep
end here since i've arrived it's just
such a buzzing city and there's so much
opportunity here and
yeah it's it's it's been great um
and i am lucky like the
coming over and london irish is a really
well supported club
and the people who are attached to it
like want to see you do well be
you know
at london irish but also off the pitch
as well and you meet a lot of great
people off the pitch as a result of the
connection you have to little uh yeah so
i've been pretty good at like putting
myself out there and trying to make the
most of that connection and make the
most of the opportunities that london
has i've loved every minute of it so far
so much so that i managed to get megan
to move over with me because we were
when i was in dublin we did it and
yeah it's kind of done two years of
long distance
and then managed to get it to come over
and and she loves it as well so yeah
we're very happily set up here at the
moment
i don't see it changing anytime soon
mate love that and your name's popped up
a few times on other guys podcast i mean
jeb talked about you constantly having
infections which probably cost your
london irish career um progressing much
further than that did
talk to me about these infections that
you constantly had
honestly i
never got another pre-jab and posture
i never had an infection so i was just
living in a cesspool of germs mess
and he was immune to it like it's his
bacteria so i
i was suffering i was going back into
the assessment of
of gem bacteria and i was getting all
these sorts of
totally seen it was like knee infections
and
any sort of wound i had it just seemed
to go
it seemed to go south on me
but
i i i had some great houseways that i
wasn't right when i first moved over um
i was i put into the academy house with
the guy called ross neal yeah he was
playing in the states at the moment with
seattle he was and he had just moved
there to school like i
just moved out home and this is his
first time
living like looking after himself and
that was
i i felt like his mother i was like
teaching me to talk teach her how to
clean off like everything was uh back to
basics so that that was a funny
experience and he was a he was a really
fun fun guy to live never forget like
you ever hear like foxes having sex at
night in the noise they may
yeah only when i was over in um landed
yeah so it's like one of the most like
harrowing noises ever you're like
someone's being murdered outside i don't
need to go check what's going on here i
don't need to quit check is everything
okay
and um
you know everybody looked fine like went
into the physio of the next day and
explained this to tom gallagher to
physio he's like
foxes like having sex and i'm like all
right okay that's fine but then it kept
happening i couldn't sleep with it and i
was like
back into the fishing room like any idea
starting to stop the foxes on the sex
outside though like you need to make
sure there's like no food outside that's
the minute
so i was like you know i made sure that
the back garden was spotless
before i go to bed every night it kept
happening and one night i came down at
like midnight to
fill up my water bottle or something
ross nails outside with a plane and a
knife and he's like
shoveling all his food on the floor
like what the hell are you doing he's
like i'm feeding the boxes
[Laughter]
i haven't been up to sleep like last two
weeks
i'm like you [ __ ] stop doing that
i never really managed to get to the
bottom he played dumb that like he
didn't really know what was going on but
i'm pretty sure he was just [ __ ] with
me
so he was a fun guy like
me first week living with him getting
the grips with each other and it was
like three of us in the top bedroom
jared ellis was the other top floor
there was one bathroom share between us
and i went into the bathroom like
unannounced and ross is there brushing
his teeth
starker's naked um
looking in the mirror and i was like all
right i looked down and i was like oh
holy [ __ ] that's like this thing was
enormous
i was like
like look back up
and he goes yeah mate i'm known for that
oh
yeah like that story got right in the
senior change room quite quickly and
built he's built a bit of a reputation
for himself at london irish and every
other club he's been to wasps harrison's
i'm sure the seattle sea wolves take
this talk to say in the same breath
about us it's kind of one of these
things you see it once you'll never
forget it
the first time you met ross neal's pace
yeah yeah you'd never forget it
um
it was the first housemate london irish
and then i moved to a jab and we could
almost dedicate a whole second episode
to live with jam
you want a character you do you do like
the stories do get repetitive but
the first the first year living when i
was sure i'd cramps my stomach every
night listen to all these stories and
then the second year he's like i
remember back in 09 when i was on tour
with canada i was like jab you told me
this story last week
me and ernie man we were hacking darts
out at the hotel window
uh and i was drinking with cod more and
i was like oh man you told me this story
100
times so
that was good we had really good fun
living together there and then i moved
in with steely and he was just
the best housemate ever like i think
he's he's had quite a few different like
housemates true rugby and i think
everyone just would speak so highly of
them
got himself in some sticky situations on
the face which he's digressed on his
podcast
i don't want to repeat any of the
stories
literally some sticky situations and
then some sticky situations
with uh
with the repercussions of them but he
was awesome as well we love fun living
together and
and yeah i enjoy i enjoyed cleaning up
the pieces that you like he left for me
sometimes
mate must have always been entertaining
living with both of those guys so good
like steely is
always the most popular guy in the
change room so like
he just it was always so busy we always
had guys around watching football and
rugby on friday nights and after parties
and all the rest it was always the
destination and luckily the the couple
that we had living downstairs were like
quite a bit older so we moved in we're
like just we don't really know what the
goal here is and then
the guy pierce is like a dj so
he'd be constantly throwing house
parties at like dj and midweek and we
obviously wouldn't kick up sticks when
you were stacking up brownie points
a couple of times like mid week he'd
like come knocking on the door he was
like oh mates i'm so sorry about last
night like
come here and we're like don't worry
we'll get you back
so
we had we had some good food and
actually one so one summer we had like a
festival on
victoria park in london and and we had
like we've had about 40 people in this
in the apartment
pierce got brought
the decks outside the tree like a bag at
house party we went to the festival came
back at like one o'clock and he got the
decks out together we weren't right on
five or six [ __ ]
literally the neighbor of dreams like he
was so much fun uh um we lived on the
same road as brendan mckibben
like i loved the podcast he did he was
another person who was just like the
glue in the changing room all the time
he was there so we had a good little
drinking crew and then uh greg tonks was
like one roll down from us as well it
was it was a
collection of lads as you would say and
we were a lot of fun one of my favorite
memories kind of from my time london
irish is
we used to do pre-match meals the night
before every game
we cook a massive spike ball like an
obscene amount of food and then we have
a massive dessert spread and then we'd
watch whatever rugby was on that night
and it was just it was it was became
like a ritual but like the bad thing
that came out it was like i wasn't the
team every week but i was still smashing
all these calories
so i was just like
ballooning i was like the same as like
as many of the other guys who were
playing week in week out we were just
getting bigger and bigger and robbie
pogba was like why are your skin full so
like worse aggressively every time we do
this well like
the the penny dropped when we when we
when i kind of like we that kind of
broke up and a few guys left the club we
stopped doing it we're a bit more
professional about
what we were eating the night before
games and the skin tones were a lot more
consistent after that
all right one of my favorite um stories
with you was uh heading to the joseph
parker fight over in wales at a sold-out
millennium stadium one of the great
nights what do you remember about that
one it really was
i fee i feel like i really we really
bonded on that trip and our relationship
went from strength to strength after
that
you got me on a bit of a dark path with
gambling it must be said jimmy i never
you know i didn't know what a bet was
and then we got into the trotting
then like six weeks later when your car
got shut down a little bit i've never
managed to get a handle on it ever since
but that that joseph parker uh thought
it was something else um
so i went down with a bunch of friends
from
from home uh ty burn sam cochlear murray
jamie davis and adam clark and uh
maybe jordan kotlin as well five guys
who have played rugby went back in back
in dublin
and toge was playing with scarlett's at
the time and they were in the european
cup quarterfinal on the friday night
yeah so we went to watch that on the
friday night and then we're like
rolling into
to aj parker and the vladimir stadium on
saturday like the weekend the dreams
yeah and we get there we're getting a
taxi into
into the stadium and i end up having a
massive barney one of my mates with
jamie i can't even remember what was
today with something shoot but we got
each other's necks all the time we live
together yeah and um
we ended up getting this stupid it was
just it just caused a bit of ag walking
into the stadium and we got into the
stadium and i see you um
is it jamison was there yeah and um i'm
like all right go over here at you guys
i'm glad to like right we're gonna go up
to our seats and we had bought our
tickets that week for like 16 quid ahead
literally in the last row in the corner
they were like the worst seats in the
house we're just going for the
i had um i was like
i'm gonna stay here have a drink with
the lads cool off and um i'll meet you
up there so
you were like your mate didn't show up
or something you had like ringside
tickets basically i think
banksy got upgraded to something because
we were supposed it was supposed to be
me jameson gibson parker marty banks and
banks ended up going to an even better
set but he must have been ranked so
because of his profile but and we we
were still in pretty good seat today and
had the extra one for you to jump off
yeah we're in the lower there like a few
rows back and you were like come watch a
couple of the prelims with us
and i go down like watch one of the
fights it's like
you can hear every punch
there's people being chucked out in a
ringside seat because there's like
scrapping going on it's like box office
stuff
and
it's like two fights out for the main
event the boys are calling me and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
so i turned my phone off and just like
i'm a terrible bloke but i didn't do the
same thing in this situation
and we had the best time i was on i was
on aj you were on parkour yeah um we
literally
we punched every punch we're done it was
a pretty crap fight it went in the
distance didn't it went in the distance
yeah and i was surrounded by loads of
kiwis but it was it was such good fun
and then
the [ __ ] storm happened when i came out
and i turned my phone on i had so many
voicemails in the blood has been like
you've changed since you moved to london
like you're dead to us you can go sleep
with your london irish friends tonight
you're not coming back to the apartment
i was like oh [ __ ]
but then
it gets worse actually i think i
wouldn't either will or you would
organized with the
um
the bouncer and walk about
giving them a heads up that we were
coming and the queue was like an hour
long and
we were walking up and the guys had been
spitting venom at me on these messengers
so i was like well we're just gonna have
to let that situation cool down until
tomorrow
we walk straight
past the lines of the queue and they're
at the back and you can see they're like
and then
and then the
um the gravel mess just started coming
and be like oh sorry vancouver let's
just forget about that come over here
and get somebody
[Laughter]
so we're
back out
it was all hugs and kisses and uh it was
all forgotten about but yeah we're we're
still all best friends thankfully boy i
definitely traded the line on that
occasion
but
why don't they great one of the great
nights
oh mate but what i do want to speak
about your um playing career at london
irish as well i mean you did i think you
played around 60 odd games not much to
talk about
why do you reckon why do you reckon your
career didn't quite progress like it
probably could have or should have
because mate every time you played you
went well you got stuck into everything
you just felt like you never really got
the opportunities or badly timed in
fiction
i honestly i don't know
if i had the answer
i i'd sell it to every other player that
um that's trying to break it none of
them could afford it like it would be
the secret there's no i don't there's no
silver bullet with these things like i
really did think i did everything right
i was very committed i was very
passionate about what i did i took my
job very seriously um i think i was a
good teammate and i was very selfless
how he did things like i literally gave
it everything and that's one thing i can
take solace in is that like i didn't
leave any stone unturned yeah um but it
just didn't happen for me you know it
was like it was a couple of times where
i kind of broke in like my first season
at london like that first season in the
academy irish 20s like sky's the limit a
couple of setbacks
got over london irish played 21 times my
first season played all the big games
after christmas and then i got a
concussion i was out for a little while
then i didn't really click with tom
coventry you know it's just
personal preference and i think that
happens to a lot of people in their
careers they don't click with coaches
yeah and then kendo and brendan vender
came in and you joined and um i got on
really well with those guys they really
valued what i brought to the environment
um didn't play as much i would like to
in the first season because of eqp stuff
and blair was ahead of me and you know
rightfully so
but i still like captain deciding a few
occasions and the second season was
going well you know i was kind of in the
matchday squad for all the start of the
season and then i blew my my ac joint
and that had happened actually under tom
coverage as well so i've done the left
one so for a while then kind of the
right one went on me and then that
season was kind of stop start i didn't
get through the season but i was uh
i was walking wounded i had like a
shoulder pad up to my ear i was actually
thinking of pain the
the shoulder pad i made it was
brilliant
done the job and i actually was i was
making them for other guys in the team
with ac problems as well
uh but yeah and then
they left those coaches left and
then declan came in and
yeah the first season they brought they
brought you know for whatever reason
they obviously didn't see me as like uh
and out now kind of first choice seven
and they felt the need to bring tj and
we were i thought we were pretty well
stocked and we had max who was we'd done
pretty well the previous season
um and blair and then but they brought
him in and then
game time was hard to come by that
season
um but i got kept on for another year
and then the following year was uh again
started the season very well had a good
preseason
and
and then got a knock in the head and
that was that was it lights out it's
funny like i always like showed big
promise in pre-seasons i loved running
and um you know i tried like trained
really hard and i'd always look and feel
really good going into the season and
kind of
typically
starting to see he's not being the mix
for for playing a good bit but i just
wasn't durable that's the bottom line
and i think there's a there's a lot to
be said for people who show up every
week
and can play through injuries and
and do it at a reasonably high level and
i just wasn't able to do that
consecutively um so
while i wasn't flavored a month with
some of the coaches you know sometimes i
just didn't even give them the headache
that they needed
to to put me in the equation all the
time
boss when i look back at it
retrospectively you know kind of as a
teenager you
you're exposed to the opportunity to
play professional rugby and that's all
you want to do at your dream job yeah
i've done it for nine years like it's
not bad it's not it's not what i set out
to do like i set out to go and play for
lancer and play for ireland and
win all the stuff that the guys who went
into the academy with have gone on to
win um but i still i i still had a lot
of fun doing it i enjoyed i loved the
process being a professional player i
was very proud to call myself
professional player i was very proud to
be associated with the clubs i've done
it with and the overriding feelings i
look back and i would like a lot of
pride and
[Music]
how it played out and was it hid knock
that you talked about was it a career
inda yeah yeah yeah so i played against
um against bayern in november 2019
in a five-man line out and
just
a big ball carrying back roll
just kind of
was just ridiculous rattle you know it
was a good collision and he just kind of
shoulder hit me in the temple and uh it
was
i had a pretty clean slate like i had
that concussion when i first moved over
london irish but by and large i was
pretty good in the lead up to that
um
and that just knocked me for six i was
having all sorts of problems that i'd
never really encountered before like
balance and mood and headaches and
everything else that goes with
concussion like it's pretty well
documented but
touch wood i'm in a pretty good place
with it now my health is is really good
and i'm not restrict this
um i would go about life on a day-to-day
basis i'm capable of working
um i just can't play contact sports so
it's probably a blessing this guy's you
know everybody takes enough batter when
you play rugby
so
it's just not even it's not even a
possibility how long did those symptoms
last of the concussions and what was
that sort of process like to
announce your retirement and confirm
that it was a career ender
so
i i got to knock in november and then i
kind of retired
august september the following year
and yeah like you know when those things
happen and you're going through the
problems that you're going through you
know you always kind of in the back your
head you know it's a possibility right
it's the same with any big big injury
like it's there's no guarant like
there's no guarantee you'll get back
from these things so
um i was still pretty optimistic that
i'd
turn it around
and i kind of would like make progress
and then tried a new stage of the return
to play protocol but just kept on
stumbling and it would set me back
significantly each time
but then when they announced that yeah
it was a bit of a grieving process
but like loads of nice messages and
uh like
some of the people that like like i said
like i remember
all my ex teammates are saying really
nice stuff and like dropping in memories
that we had together and
that was really nice um and then some of
the guys that i looked up to
growing up like dropping the emails and
stuff it was pretty
it was it was it was it was cool it was
a bit actually it was a weird year to
finish and i think a lot there's a lot
of people in the same boat as me so i'm
not looking for sympathy but like it was
it was covered right so it was like
there's no end the season ball there was
um
it was like not even like a send that
send off pistol or anything like that
there was no nothing going on stadium so
the bit it was rubbish that way um but
everyone in the world same thing like
those people graduate from college and
school and stuff that
people weddings cancel so it's like
you're not you're not isolating sledded
from that sort of stuff
that was how it finished and then i cut
i got a camper van with
my girlfriend meg
and i drove around the south coast of
france together and she was in between
jobs at the time as well it was just a
really nice way to kind of process it
all and
kind of reflect i was actually you know
looking back on it going
that was
that was uh
it was fun uh that was you know it was a
great experience and now it was time for
the next chapter in my life trying to
map out what what that's gonna look like
and
and then threw myself into like a
startup role
in an entire a new role in a tech
startup in sales because i always felt
that that's kind of where my
my sweet spot would lie
i've done that for a year really enjoyed
it learned a lot
and
then went to do the apprentice
i was short-lived and then i actually
had a bit of a like
an ether kind of like it was apprentice
finished i kind of booked off while i
kind of like booked off this time so i
went home and spent some time my parents
and i wasn't very busy i
had a lot too much time to think and
then that was probably actually when the
penny like dropped at how much i missed
rugby and yeah
probably a little bit of uh you know
you're you're very everyone's made aware
that transition is really hard and it's
a big part of your identity and so many
people love doing it and i was
definitely one of those people
but
the year that had gone by i was like
bad like i was like
still chat to the boy he's like i don't
feel totally removed from us
i'm busy um i spent last summer
in a camper van
in the south of france as opposed to
a pre-season i was like this is
fine but then when
you pause and you're like
ah
i haven't found exactly what i wanted to
do next like the bar wasn't up and
running or
hadn't started this new job and you're
like crap like what's next um
i thought i had all this figured out and
like evidently i don't
so that was that was a bit crap but um
you know just
dust yourself down and just put yourself
out there and go again and
then we got the green light to do the
301 for brentford london irish and then
i
you know six weeks i think we about six
weeks from the day we got to go ahead to
the first game we're gonna do and that
was
i was brilliant fun like me and topsy
like dale boy and rodney like going
around trying to get this bar ready
we're setting up bank accounts like
doing test runs with the
the horse box and land rover the wheel
fell off the horse box and then we got
that up and running
and then i started interviewing for for
jobs and then
luckily got got a job with an amazing
company called fys it's like a
fortune 500 company it's in the fintech
space so it's a really
exciting area to work in that there's a
massive career opportunity in it and
yeah i'm busy i'm in a really good spot
now actually which is which is great is
that the dream to go up the tech space
rankings
yeah why did i pick tech
well my girl like megan's been in tech
sales pretty much my whole life and a
lot of my friends have and they've done
really well in it and
it always just seemed like a career path
that you can get into with doesn't have
massive barriers to entry
and there's a lot of money to be made
if if you're good at it so that was that
was the incentive to get in there and at
the moment it feels like the right thing
i'm starting to i'm starting to speed
the lingo i started to get it
and i'm well able to chat to people so
that's half the battle but then there's
there are some like a lot of
transferables with the discipline and
it's very very important like when i
played rugby like i was very good at
like going to pilates doing my recovery
and
getting those extra weight sessions in
to keep the body mass up and you know
all those things are
applicable to work but or in sales but
they're just they're slightly different
you know it's industry reading it's
getting your cold calling done it's
it's having good hygiene and where in
your crm where you manage all your deals
so there is crossover just figuring out
what those transferable skills are so
yeah and the other thing about it is
that like one of the special things
about playing fashion rugby is you're in
a change room in an environment where
by and large everyone wants to be there
and everyone's made a lot of sacrifices
and work really hard to be there it's an
elite environment like it's everyone is
striving for those one percent to get
better and that's
that's special that's cool it keeps you
on your toes and it's like a it's a
healthy pressure
and from what i've seen so far in fis
it's it's by and largest everyone's kind
of the same boat they're just doing in a
different career like an
incredibly
driven group of people the ones it's 55
000 people right so i haven't met anyone
i've
been exposed to a handful of people but
they're all
at the top end of what they do and
always looking for ways to get better
you know as an organization and as
individuals so
that's cool um
yeah and for the 301 bar what where do
you see that that one going do you just
see it as a side hustle do you see that
as something that's gonna take over the
world
um it won't take over the world that's
that's for sure because well i'd like it
to but it's it's a mobile bar at the end
of the day but um it has the potential
to be a really really good business
so we topsy and i
very fortunate to have the platform that
london irish have given us to start the
business
and that's been great like long arch
fans have been so supportive so far
we've had some great days down there
some really cold days uh like doing it
in november and the depths of december
was was tough but we're out the other
side of that now like
you're seeing it come up on the
instagram all the the fans like putting
up stories and saying how much they
enjoyed it
so that's wicked like that's it makes it
all worthwhile
and the great thing about having a
tenancy at a the sports stadium is that
they play sports in the winter and the
high season for these events
is is summer
and we're we're busy at work at the
moment trying to fill that calendar
with with sports festivals with
food music festivals with
food festivals
and you know it's a challenge it is it's
very tricky like we've got these
opportunities and we're going
right topsy's schedule is stacked like
with tv stuff
and i'm working a full-time job that's
very demanding and it's a two-man band
and we've got some great staff to help
us on game day we
we probably need someone to bridge that
gap
in terms of like from an operation
standpoint so
it generated we've got the the demand is
there which is reassuring but uh
figuring out a bridge
or yeah like a bridge to get to to be
able to satisfy that demand is kind of
working through at the moment
but it is it is a side hustle and i
think it will probably remain that way
um but it'll hopefully be a lucrative
side hustle and one that
very importantly keeps us really
connected to rugby because um you know
hypocrisy will stay connected to it
regardless because he's a legend but
um
it's it's a nice outlet for me to go
there i said that i was like
there's just like no way this ever would
have happened where it after you forget
about me like
five minutes after i walked out the door
well it does sound like a good bath and
i'm looking forward to getting over
there one day back to the stadium and
trying
jimmy it'd be epic one of the things
that we're pushing really hard with the
club and they're really supportive of it
is we want this to be like
to be an outlet for x players to come
back and attach themselves to the club
because there have been so many like
amazing players that have gone through
the club and done great things there and
then it's probably been a little bit of
a disconnect in terms of opportunities
to come back and really support the club
afterwards
and so
you know in what we've tried to do is
like each week we have like an ex-player
club legend come down and like mix with
the fans and they get looked after by
the club at the game
and it's working really well um
the fans love it the club are really
supportive we just want to get build out
more and more so instead of it just
being one player coming down to each
week you know we've got 10x players
coming down that's the place where they
come to connect
do business and
stay connected to the game so
that's part that's all part of the
process as well mate that sounds awesome
and i love seeing players go out there
and try their own little side hustles
like that it's awesome to see but as
always we've gone to our instagram for
some questions and mate when reality tv
stars come on the show
plenty of questions come in even though
you are our first but first question ask
him about the sweat gate when he was vip
at wimbledon okay what's wrong with the
story
so
now the message we've been like do you
wanna go to wimbledon today it was the
first day um of tennis and i said
absolutely yeah 100 and he goes okay put
on something nice like where we've been
looked after and i was like grand
they're dressed fancy here so looked at
my wardrobe i had like nothing like
nothing appropriate
he's like right blazer there white
t-shirt pair of chinos that kind of make
that look good
so throw all that off
not taken into account for the fact that
it's like 33 degrees outside and it's
humid in london you know what the
summers are like here yeah
it's hectic
so
he's like right meet me
outside uh
this guy i'd like this time because
we're going in then he's like cool
i'll do that and i'll jump in a taxi and
traffic is chaos getting in there i'm
like come on drop me it's like gate one
and he's like look it's just around the
corner here gate one is there they're
cool so i go to go around the corner
it's like gate 16 and it's like five to
twelve like [ __ ]
i look at my phone on google maps and
it's like a 15 minute walk away
[ __ ] i don't want to you know i'm a
guest so i don't want to cause any
hassle like getting in and
yeah all the rest that goes with it so i
start like sprinting
i'm running around i'm like actually a
nice breeze here like i'm really fit
like i don't sweat that much you should
be fine
i get there and then we go into this
lounge and then it's like just it's like
it's sweat like you've never seen before
it's just broken in out of everywhere
i'm just so uncomfortable it's like
dripping over eyebrows
and we had this uh south african horse
test and she was like are you okay
go to the toilet like trying to sort
this out so like
pop myself there like kind of get a
handle on it go back down sit on this
like leather stool and have a few like
cocktails
it's all
starting to like regulate my body
temperature and feeling good about today
again i'm like right i've turned this
around
and then
she's like all right we're gonna go to
uh santa cord for the for the game
i jump up and i like walk ahead she's
like oh my god
connor got her oh my god carter uh
do you want to go to the toilet you talk
about like turn around
on her hands and knees pretty much
laughed at me she's like you're both
you're bull but i was like i took my
phone
so when i
run into the toilet like check my rear
end and i'm wearing beige cheetos
right from like the top of my ass crack
right down to my crotch is just like the
worst swamp bars you've ever seen in
your life
it was humiliating and then
when he comes in he's like what's the
problem like i can't i'm thought of
going home like this day is just done
like i'm done
no no it's fine just tied him tight a
blazer around your waist
and then
i've done that i just remember like
going out and had like a massive sweat
patch here like two huge ones here and
niall's walking ahead he's getting
popped and i'm getting caught in the
backdrop and he's gone
i just remember like
sitting
watching the game and i was like really
like down here trying to like ventilate
my heart so i wasn't able to join at all
i kept saying i was like can i just
leave like this is so unenjoyable
they wouldn't let me know i was there i
was their entertainment for today oh
that is so good what a yarn blair cowan
thanks for sending that one in he never
disappoints but he's also got another
one here ask him about the time he made
an outrageous false accusation that
helani kicked him in the head
ah yeah that's a
katrina grand yard
it was like it's one of those horrible
drills here in like a 10 by 10 grid and
it's eight on eight it's pick and go and
it's just hell
it's good it's pretty it's a pretty
spicy trading session
and then
there was a pod set up like a couple of
meters away from the breakdown and uh
helani
went in at half bash the puppet to them
and like i should have just let like he
tilani was very skillful she just let
him pop it to them and
came to the ball and i'm down over the
ball and he
roots me in the iris as hard as he can
and like
nearly like sends my testicles into my
mouth like it was so painful
you [ __ ] kicked me in the head
kicked me into that it was like
we did you kicked your horse
so then that that haunted me for like a
year or two like
that you kicked me in the head like
that's all everyone used to say to me
anytime we went into like
that mv10 drill and i've got great
voilage over it oh man it didn't take
much over there right you did one wrong
move like that it's it sticks
forever honestly yeah yeah these tanks
follow you around okay next one uh how
much does he love a turtleneck out of
ten i do love a turtle i was actually
wearing a turtleneck
at work today and i was gonna go
straight where the threat leg i was like
oh it's a good look wearing a turtleneck
on a lovely podcast
that's why i was a couple of minutes
later
so kudos to you gemini
[Laughter]
like he can't pull me up on flash and
stuff anyways he was i used to get
called the the worst dresser in the
squad all those like quick foreign
questions but
it was jeb every day of the week or jeff
cross one of those two yeah you had good
fashion sense didn't you thanks you
could pull it off i like that okay next
one what's your favorite nyle song um
what's my favorite novel song oh slow
hands is the best one yeah like in terms
of like it's just been an absolute
it's another song that's taken over the
world
um so yeah that'd probably be it did you
prefer him solo or in one direction i
actually i think he's an incredible solo
artist like i went to see him to play in
the greek in los angeles a couple years
ago and it was
of course you have the personal affinity
there but it was definitely the best gig
i've ever been to incredible um like
this
outdoor theater um
he sold it out i think two or three
nights in a row um
i went to everyone i went consecutively
each night like
well he is he's an awesome awesome
artist and really good life well i had
some great nights at one day as well um
and the old two uh but yeah probably
slow hands his new album heartbreak
rider was with class he never got the
torah because because of colvin which
was a real shame but it was it was
really cool he was like rehearsing in a
studio ones where it was banned
and he invited me and megan there's the
two of us sitting on the couch like two
meters away from me played the whole set
through and it was just like
like money can't buy this yeah it's just
so [ __ ] cool and
i was good at firm that he didn't get to
tour that bus i think he's writing a new
album at the moment it's gonna be good
nice you should feature on it what song
did you sing when you did your pedal
fall under nourish up the front of the
bus so i signed angels by robbie
williams
and they didn't get paddled
even though like typically you do
because it's such a cliche song i've
done a good
job and tom court got up
tom court got up and sang some song and
it was
bombing so badly and i
being a good teammate that i am i jumped
in and tried to help him and then he
ended up getting off the path and i had
to go into it
i'm surprised you got off you're one of
those guys who i'd imagine no matter how
well you sang you were getting peddled
yeah i did a good job but you must have
a good voice
okay next one ask him about jebediah's
room and sunbury when he had a scrap
with darren allison and there was blood
everywhere
oh yeah yeah dice has like a cauliflower
uh after a game and they had a couple of
beers uh
in some breed
we came back and just me and dodge just
ended up
like wrestling on the ground it was
pretty intense and
i ended up raping his colleagues larry
around but um
it just was a mess it was like uh a
crime scene there was like cream carpets
everywhere it was a total disaster i
don't think the lads got the deposit
boxes
okay what's the thing you missed most
about playing footy so
i look like i said earlier i love the
process of being the player like the
training like the the feeling of just
being pushing yourself to the limit and
feeling great about it and looking after
yourself and that was something i really
really enjoyed uh
i loved it
the camaraderie that came with the t
with the changing room
then of course playing games but i don't
admit really i don't miss the games
that much um
i was one of those guys i did get very
wound up around games i put a lot of
pressure on myself and always incredibly
sore after them um
[Music]
some more i doubt i probably missed
the training and the lifestyle and the
the lads more so the cracker and the
change room but that can't last forever
right
yeah
yeah would you would you be the same do
you miss the game no i don't miss the
games at all honestly yeah yeah i i just
remember
you you just used to love the
the construct and the attack plan and
the detail we go into and like we were
literally like we so many games we would
have lost by like 40 points and like
we're on the bus home
and you have the laptop out be like
i'd be like hey like just put it away
like we've just gone home
i remember it was one game i think it
was
sail away and we ran this play where we
hit down the middle and i had like a
blocking role to play it was actually it
was against northampton away and i came
on for like 10 minutes it was a close
game i think we already might lost by
score yeah
my role was to block the the first
offender at the breakdown so he'd like
move away from the breakdown i kind of
step in his line and then we shoot
through and
i miss my role like i just didn't block
them well and
the pass went to hand and then he made
the tackle and like if he didn't there
was no fullback to be seen
i remember like i knew i [ __ ] up and
you were like gilly
[Laughter]
but yeah i always just thought i was
like you're just going to go on to be an
awesome we'll be coach so i'm glad to
hear you're still in the environment oh
mate it's nice to hear
okay back to you
next question
where are ireland going to finish at the
rugby world cup
it looks really promising at the moment
they look so good they're just some
so many different points of attack
they're so like just very unpredictable
about how to do things and move they
move the ball really well
so i just think it looks really positive
but we do have a really nasty habit of
peaking two years out and
it's not delivering on the big stage so
hopefully andy farley can channel this
optimism and kind of carry it through
and keep getting them keep making them
better between now and uh between now
and oracle 100 anyways it is going to be
an awesome world cup looking forward to
that one but last question for the
gilmeister best piece of advice you have
for a water led listener
i've always be like quite a warrior like
definitely when i look back on time
playing rugby like over taught i
overthought like everything and
like i get like wound up about small
niggly injuries that didn't need to
that didn't deserve as much thinking
time and anxiety that i gave them and
worry about like contract situations and
yeah i'd worry about transitioning even
though it was miles of the way and
that it's just wasted energy um i know
it's a hard thing to do but if i'm
starting to get better i still do
overthink things a lot but
i do look at some of my friends that
like definitely don't do that and i'm
quite envious of i'm working towards
that at the minute so
yeah just like try not to dwell on the
small things and
worry it really is wasted energy i know
it's impossible to avoid it at times but
if you cover some coping strategies or
just trying to rationalize what's
actually important and what deserves
your
your time or your energy and worry more
often than not
most things don't deserve it yeah
so that would be
yeah just try not worry about things too
much and enjoy life while you can right
because
that's very very important 100
and what a way to finish the podcast
some of the best advice we've had on the
podcast today
but it has been a pleasure to have you
on um absolute legend someone i did love
playing with over at london irish we had
some good times over there and you're a
man who has been involved in a lot of
stories that we've had on from some of
the lads already so it's been awesome to
get you on and hear your side of things
and awesome to see what you're doing
post footy and hearing how that
transition went so
it's been awesome insight into your
journey and really appreciate you coming
on the podcast thanks so much jimmy you
are a lad cheers bye